-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
I sent out the...
and I asked you guys to share
a weird or funny idea
that you have for an app.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so, thank you for playing along!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one is from @pdb435.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Sounds good."
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @RedEye54034.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I like the way he spelled Wavr.
-Yeah, Wavr.
[ Laughter ]
-I love how you spelled
Wavr, too.
Just take the "E" out.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's an app.
It's cool, hip.
-It's cool, man.
-Wav...r.
-Wavr.
[ Laughter ]
-Ermahgerd.
-It should be W-v-r, Wvr.
-Yeah, with all in one thing.
-Dude, did you get Wvr?
-I got Wvr.
-Oh, I got the Wvr.
-I got Wvrr.
Shoot.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, hey.
-Yeah.
-What's that?
-Oh, hey.
Hey.
Hello.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay...
[ Grunting ]
-Kkhh!
[ Laughter ]
♪ Wavr! ♪
Wavr.
[ Announcer voice ]
The new Meta.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @FencerToni.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
They should do that.
-Now.
-Invent that immediately!
-Yes.
-One button.
-That is genius.
This one is from @TheTicTocMan.
-TicTocMan, God bless him.
-Yeah. He says...
Oh, hey.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Kyle has zero stars.
-Oh, hell, no.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @CX-Henderson.
He says...
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
I like that.
This one's
from @BeatriceRLynn.
She says...
[ Cheering and applause ]
"Sign me up for whatever!
Come on!"
-"Take my money."
-"Uh, no way I'm going
to get in this thing."
-"I got to read this."
-"I read the whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
A couple points
I don't agree with."
-"Line 36 and line 145."
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @winklerpgh.
He says...
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ The Roots playing
poignant jazz tune ]
-"Uh, I just started doing
CrossFit
and I feel great, you know?
I just --
the best shape of my life.
Right now is when --
I just --
Hey, where are you going man?
Alright.
Hey, take care.
I want to thank my agents
and, uh,
Lola and Tony, it's too late.
Past your bedtime.
Go to sleep."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Why do you keep playing?
[ Laughter ]
App is broken.
-No, it's working.
-This one is
@luisa-brookes12.
She says...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-"Oh, no!
What's gone wrong?!"
-This last one's
from @schwagmusic13.
-Schwag!
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites go to...